it's the biggest protest in budapest in
years
i'm here with david a 23 year old jewish
hungarian he's one of the three young
people i and my fellow reporters will
meet during the show three people who
face discrimination
look
it would be good if you would like
record them because they are like the
far right people standing on the other
side of the street
we're not here long before a group of
neo-nazis turns up on the scene
i don't know if they're
really here to protest for the freedom
of internet perhaps they just want to
provoke as you heard before like he just
shouted jidok which means jews so yeah
probably they want to provoke
the people
how does that make you feel like when
you see that i'm afraid of the future of
the country and i'm afraid that it's
like uh instead of tolerance where we're
talking about it and what you hear this
this demonstration has nothing to do
with the jews nothing to do with
anything but he was shouting jews
the protest is supposed to be about the
new internet tax but more than 10 000
hungarians are here to vent their
general frustration with the government
but if the revolution is starting and
people go in we're going with them okay
david is surprised and happy that so
many people have turned up to make their
voices heard
but this enthusiasm turns into
disappointment when the thoughts show up
again
i don't think that's a demonstration
demonstration should end like this
like in my in the ideal world i think
it's like it would be the still the
whole crowd is coming here and they have
a silent protest and not breaking
windows or
chanting against jews or gypsies
where do you think is this
is this all going to
i know it's like
i have plans to leave but
still my home and
my hometown
i know
but i i have like strong intention to
leave but
i can't tell you which is gonna be
stronger
the jewish community has always been an
essential part of hungarian society
these days as has been the case in the
past they're the targets of growing
anti-semitism
to avoid confrontation many hungarian
jews prefer to live in a kind of bubble
david tells me but it seems almost
impossible to escape anti-semitism even
here in the jewish quarter
would you find that often
yeah
yeah but we don't cause there are
swastikas as anti-semitic incidents
because it's not directly against jews
and there is too many of them so it's
no use to deal with
them david watches out for anti-semitic
signs and slogans online and here on the
streets of budapest
and he leads a group of volunteers they
meet up at the israeli cultural
institute where they work on their
facebook page the forum against
anti-semitism
they collect and post acts of cyber hate
and present a regular report to the
community i'm surprised at how well
david and his friends seem to take it
but there are cases that really upset
him as you can see it says
on the wall that is the jews are rats
and this is a kindergarten and he's a
father and it's he published it on his
own facebook page find it really sad
because like
this is a place where little children go
uh
every
every day and this is if this is their
environment
keem one
given
david is working to find more courage he
takes me to his krav maga training krav
maga was invented by a hungarian israeli
martial arts trainer to defend the
jewish quarter against fascist groups in
the 1930s
today it's a popular self-defense method
developed for the military in israel and
security forces worldwide
so why is it important for you to do
craft magazine if one day i will be
attacked as a jew in hangaring that just
gives me more confidence and makes me
more secure that i could defend myself
but uh
i also i i also think that this is like
nothing not in the first place or maybe
not in the second this is what krav maga
actually teaches you that you need to be
prepared for any attacks and you need to
handle
every every conflict
and the potential for conflict seems to
be growing
more and more hungarians support the
neo-nazi party yopic
it now has 20 percent of the seats in
parliament
i asked for an interview with the yobik
politician several times but no one was
willing to talk to me
it was pretty much expressed by the
by the i want to know how this far-right
populist party can gain one out of every
five votes in hungary but this is
something i think a huge after 2006
when the far right
in hungary became
more
coherent more institutionalized and more
strong it was the moment when
anti-semitism
began to rise so there is a clear
political driver behind it there is
there was a crisis period political
crisis even economic crisis australia
measures and a new emergent political
force yobik that could exploit the world
these frustrations and name a specific
outgroup the jews and they are the one
who blame
growing racism is worrying many people
here in hungary the duwani street
synagogue in budapest jewish quarter is
the largest synagogue in europe
in 1944 around 800 000 jews lived in
hungary by the year's end some 560 000
had been murdered most of them deported
to concentration camps by the nazis
david lost three of his great
grandparents during the holocaust but
doesn't want to focus on the past
so you should you should move on this is
like
this is what is called history because
this is something that's happened in the
past and you need to move on and maybe
to to prevent that it wouldn't happen
again but the ways is not to like to
talk about it all the time
and what about your parents did they
talk about that and did they did they
taught you about about judaism about
being a jew and about all the the
heritage
uh we actually never really talked about
it in the family
but um
so they don't anything say they don't
say anything directly but
they always uh
i felt like they're always trying to
give me the the impression that like
being jewish
is like it comes with being victimized
david's parents are not happy about
their son becoming active in the jewish
community
they worried because of what their
family experienced in the past
but david and his friends are determined
to oppose the growing anti-semitism in
their home country with a new generation
self-confidence